hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today i'm going
to be remaking a video i've had a lot of
requests to remake some of the more
popular videos since some of my older
videos had some poor sound quality so
that's what i'm going to do today in the
future i will be doing the same for some
of the other videos you can always tell
from the title i'm going to put in there
remake and parenthesis so if you do see
that it is a remake i will be going over
a few new things in the videos and
talking about a few new things so it
still is worthwhile to check out but if
you see it you don't need a post and say
you already made a video on this i know
I was asked to and that's what I'm gonna
do so today we're going to be looking at
open verse closed positions and this is
one of the most common things that the
chess player needs to know and it's
probably one of the more important
things and it comes down to the pawn
structure and this is going to determine
how you really look at your minor pieces
and how you need to strategize a game
plan around your minded pieces how
you're going to play that so the first
thing we need to look at is the pawn
structure as you can look at the pawn
structure here this is an open game an
open game is defined by a lot of open
room in the middle for pieces to move
around at the same time the pawns can
still move around a lot
there's no fixation in the pawns they
can still move freely and this makes it
an open game now on an open game
as you may imagine bishops reign supreme
so you have two minor pieces you have
your Knights and your bishops and we're
going to be looking at the bishops here
and the bishops are really going to be
the pieces that do well in an open game
and that is because let me go and
highlight them here the bishops want to
have a lot of room to move around
they're really work well if they have a
lot of squares that they can attack and
move to and if it's open game they can
do just that
and vice versa if it's a close game and
there's a lot of pawns in the middle and
we'll go over that in just a second if
the bishops can't move around they're
kind of worthless so a lot of times
you'll hear people say you not prefer
bishops over Knights or I prefer knights
and bishops well it really depends in
the situation of the game because if
it's a close game a bishop pair is not
really that great of an advantage but
early on if you have a bishop pair a lot
of people say that's an advantage
because a lot of people can easily open
up the game it's later on when the game
is closed that people will then prefer
Knights / bishops because bishops can't
move around any more so in this case
this is an open game as we saw there's
still a lot of room for the pawns to
move and the center is not locked up so
bishops are going to reign supreme and
bishops are going to be more valuable
than Knights even though they're both
three points so go ahead and take a look
it's blacks move here and what would you
say would be black's best move here
thinking along the lines of what we just
talked about bishops being more
important than
nights go and take them if you want to
pause it and the best move hopefully you
came up with is night to be four and
this is attacking this Bishop on d3
which is a very good Bishop the
LightSquared Bishop is one of the more
important minor pieces for white and at
the same time this Bishop is very good
because it's an open game and vice versa
this Knight is not as good that's not
saying it's bad but it's not as good as
a bishop because it is an open game as
you can see there's nowhere for the
bishop to move without this trade
happening you can't move to c4 he can be
captured and they can't move along this
diagonal here or else he's going to be
captured as well in this situation
you're going to be trading a knight for
a bishop so you're trading a three point
piece for a three point piece and a lot
of people look at that and say you know
who cares they're the same but if you
really look at chess and study it you'll
see that in different situations
different pieces are better and so it's
these little things in these little
subtleties in chess that will give you
an advantage yes you are trading a
knight for Bishop but later on in the
game this is going to be very good for
you so let's go ahead and take a look at
another example we'll take a look at a
closed game and see how that's different
from an open game and how we should play
accordingly
let's take a look at this example and
you can see here this is the pawn
structure a little bit different it's a
little more fixed the pawns aren't going
to be moving and at the same time the
center of the board it's clogged up it's
locked up and so this is going to be a
closed position and in this type of game
Knights are going to fare much better
than bishops yes they are again both
three points but Knights are going to
fare much better because as you can see
let's take a look at this Bishop here on
g7 he's not going anywhere he can't the
center's blocked up his range of motion
is not very high at the same time these
Knights can hop over pieces so these
Knights can get all over the board even
though there's pawns everywhere they can
navigate anywhere on the board they want
to because they can hop over pieces so
with that said let's go ahead and take a
look at this close position that's white
smooth and what should be White's best
move in this situation knowing that
Knights are going to be play better than
bishops so go in a minute take a minute
if you want to pause it and hopefully
you came up with Bishop to b5 as you can
tell here the bishop is pinning down
this Knight to the queen there's nothing
the knight can do here or else he's
going to lose his queen so he's going to
have to give up his knight and once we
do that once we trade off this knight in
our Bishop we're going to have a good
minor piece and black is going to have a
bad minor piece or now it's going to be
able to roam all over the board and the
bishops basically going to be worthless
so yes we do have the same amount of
material but we have much better pieces
than black discs so this is going to be
a better game for white the advantage is
not huge but at the same time it is
advantage and anytime you can get an
advantage in chess it's usually good
take
so this is one of the few things that
you can take in your chest learning
anytime in the middle game you always
want to take a look at if it's an open
game or a close game and this is really
going to determine how you look at your
minor pieces people always ask me what's
something I should look at in my game
you know I understand the openings but
once I get to the middle game well
there's a lot of different things as far
as tactics and strategy but one of the
main things you want to know is is it an
open game or a close game and act
accordingly so hope you guys enjoy this
video if you haven't already please
subscribe and I'll see you guys in the
next video thanks for watching